I learn to walk again and it's just one
of my first steps running for Ferguson
City Council of 2019
[Applause]
welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday you just heard from Lesley
McSpadden head she is the mother of
Michael Brown the teenager who was shot
and killed by a police officer in
Ferguson Missouri four years ago this
week the incident sparked protests in
Ferguson and around the country her run
for City Council mirrors that of Wesley
Bell a concerned Ferguson citizen who
won a council seat and is now poised to
take on an even bigger public role
Democratic primary upset of seven terms
st. Louis County Prosecutor Bob
McCulloch Tuesday all but assures him
victory in November there is no
Republican candidate this is a
tremendous office here and if you
tampers with that he'd be making an
enormous mistake what makes the win so
stunning is that four years ago as a
community we have to get involved Bell
stood on the front lines of protests in
Ferguson Missouri trying to quell anger
after the shooting death of Michael
Brown by police officer Darren Wilson
Bell promised to delivers change to
policing in his community after a grand
jury found there was not enough evidence
to indict Wilson you're next
City Councilman change came after a
strategic door-knocking campaign earned
him a seat on the Ferguson City Council
what was the need you saw I saw I need
food and leadership three years later
he's poised to lead the most impactful
crime-fighting office in the county how
did you win this seat what we went into
this campaign the mindset that we have I
should say was that we were going to
focus on the issues we wanted to give
people a reason to be inspired to go to
the polls as opposed to the fear and
and antagonism that we see with a lot of
elected officials and and that message
resonated as we as we can see bail ran
on a criminal justice reform platform
one that included devoting resources for
treating addiction and mental health
curbing the revolving door of mass
incarceration and moving focus from
misdemeanor traffic tickets to serious
crimes the city of Ferguson has been
under a federal consent decree since
2016 in that time the monitor dismissed
all but 1,700 of the nearly 8,000
misdemeanor cases filed against citizens
and for a sitting next door to st. Louis
now the nation's murder capital it's a
delicate balancing act between
crime-fighting and community policing
here's the thing we're not going to
focus our our resources our prosecutors
on nonviolent for example possessions of
marijuana instead we're going to
reallocate those resources the job of
the prosecutor's office is to make st.
Louis County safer was it important to
unseat the chief prosecutor I've been
practicing for 17 years I've seen the
the policies of this office with respect
to lack of commitment to virtue
diversionary programs and the cash bail
system with respect to nonviolent
offenders who are going to be released
anyway but yet still being held on bonds
that they can't afford to me it's a
matter of principle this is where I'm
from this is my home on Thursday the
anniversary of Brown's death family
friends
and Michael Browns seniors pay tribute
to the team and this election outcome
the whole city is happy man did Wesley
be I made it in we get a chance to get
fruit fried trout but that's no
guarantee though he's criticized
McCullough's investigation Bell has not
committed to reopening the case
promised to ensure a deathlike grounds
won't happen again
Ferguson brought an awareness what we've
seen over the last four years is a
community that is having the difficult
conversations the uncomfortable
conversations which I think are
important he has a tremendous base of
support primarily because he's so
measured in how he talks to people and
how he relates to people he was a
criminology professor a lawyer a judge a
city councilman now he's poised to be
the next chief prosecutor and very
plain-spoken very direct I like when you
ask him how he got into public life in
the first place you know and he says
lack of leadership out there right and
it's a great model of you can protest
what's the next step how do you start
making change and that's what he's doing
Michael Brown's mother right working
within the system and I think that a lot
of people are seeing now that you have
to work inside the system often to
change the system so we'll see what
happens great great piece Michelle thank
you yes again